it's like man this thing is doing 200
million you know impressions per day can
you talk about app 11 because you said
something so the other day I was talking
to someone about businesses and I'm like
when it's working do you know it's
working what's that feel like and you
made a comment earlier like it's the
first time I've ever seen we're just
this is what working feels like right
what what what what was that like it's
it's the feeling of like like when you
when you're you know slamming on your
brakes in the car and the car is kind of
doing its own thing and you're like I'm
not controlling the car it is just
flowing on its own it's like it's that
feeling where you know you're you build
all these products and even at Apple oh
and we did nine ideas before that I've
done this for a long time where I'm just
trying idea after idea I try to get
people to use it you're looking for all
these good signals and you're trying to
spot it and then when it's really
working
it's not about spotting it it's so
obvious that there's no question that
it's working and so it's all the charts
are flying up but then every day you're
not even like man is it working or is it
not
it's so obvious like I got to do X Y & Z
to solve you know these problems that
are coming up kind of day in and day out
and so it's definitely a feeling where
the pull from the market is so strong
that there's no there's no middle ground
it's I always thought it was like oh
it's I'm gonna kind of realize when I'm
close to it but it's actually very
binary it's like you're here and it's
not working and you're trying to push
into the market what you need to do but
when it happens it just kind of takes
off and you know I just I don't have
really good analogies for yet except for
that like it just it's like the loss of
control the market is in control almost
and you're just like trying to catch up
and like you know get into that mindset
of like okay great this is working
we're gonna keep like pushing whatever
we need to do to kind of support this
case what was the revenue growth I mean
you guys were at zero then was it like
one month it could have been like 20
grand the next month it was like a
million I mean was it that substantial
it wasn't that crazy but I think the
interesting thing that I learned was
there you know there were a lot of
players in the market where you'd go to
this weather app right and the weather
what do you like you know you never
realized the scale of some of these apps
even at that time it's like man this
thing is doing 200 million
you know impressions per day and I'm
like a whether at like really like why
is it so big and then you're not great
if we get this customer these things can
happen and so I think the weather the
weather app does how many impressions I
think I forgot which weather app it was
whether it was weather bug or the
weather app but it was like 200 million
impressions a day like and I was like I
was really surprised at some of the
scale of some of these apps and like you
know yes we had the best ad platform yes
we made you know we made all these small
tweaks to the product to like make it
work better and we made our server scale
and we did all these things but I think
to me the fascinating thing was there
were all these major players you didn't
actually realize how big some of these
opportunities were and kind of working
at Apple oven I was like wait
I want to go do this and like when I
left there it was like I'm not like a
huge fan of like ad products like
naturally it that's not the product that
I get excited about I love money so I
like great it's a fantastic business I
like that and then I was like oh I'm
gonna go make these apps and games that
are gonna go do this and actually that's
how I ran into Sean I think he had
checked out one of my games after
AngelList was that right yeah I saw mine
AngelList
and I was like something doesn't add up
either this guy's full of cuz who
would leave this company that's crushing
it like most people when you finally hit
a grand slam you want to do the victory
lap and people stay for seven years and
then they write this cheesy letter about
how great the journey has been and
they're finally ready for their next
chapter he basically left after three
years you weren't even fully vest in
right yeah I left a little bit on the
table again I'm not complaining cuz
everything's been fantastic and but it
was something counterintuitive I was
like why would this guy leave either he
got kicked out he got fired he's not
good bubble blah I was like or this
guy's amazing he really just does love
like his story was like I just love
startups I want to build something that
consumers use not really an ad tech
platform and he was like I was
interested in mobile because I saw how
big these mobile apps were on our ad
network so he locked himself in his
bedroom it's like I'm gonna learn mobile
in the next 6 months and he just built a
bunch of Android games and then I saw
him on Twitter tweeting back with people
who played his game and I was like dude
none of my developers all the developers
I have in my company that are great none
of them would ever go tweeted a customer
and be like hey you know I'm gonna fix
that bug and I can make this better
hey what do you think about this sounds
like there's something different about
this guy what apps were you shocked at
how big they were
why their app does 200 no the casino
game I mean that's not shocking is it um
the size of it was definitely shocking
just because you all assume they're big
and they're addictive but then that and
then candy crush in their initial rise
was the first time in the industry where
I heard like men like dis ting is a
money printing machine it's like you
know they would you know and not all
this was at applo and i said once you're
an ad tech you're like learning about
the industry you're meeting other people
and you're like hey these guys are
willing this blanket pee but eight bucks
for a user in the US and I'm like okay
well that seems pretty expensive like
why are they doing that
like how much they make eight dollars
what they're spending yeah I think at
that time it was like hey if we're like
a meal you know 18 to 35 or something it
might be eight bucks or something like
that and then on the other side I talked
to somebody over there and I'm like
they're like yeah dude we make like 20
bucks on them like in like seven days
and I'm like and maybe those numbers are
slightly off but like they were making a
multiple to where you were like wait so
you just have this machine where you
just press this button and you put in
money and you know seven days later
three times more money come out and I'm
like wow like how do I get that
my bank account every single day to go
do that well you guys had that a little
bit with that blevins yeah I didn't have
that right I don't know if you're this
company you're vested you have a shared
interest in the long run but you know me
being me I was like I want that like I
want the ability to have that and then
the freedom to work on things that I'm
really excited about and so I tried that
obviously it's a lot harder than just
you know one person in their bedroom
doing it but what did Adam Apple of and
say was he like this just we had no idea
or was he methodical and an item is so
fantastic at execution that is just like
he's like a machine it's like you know
when when the thing I really loved about
him and the things I learned the most
from him were like when you wanted to go
do something like you know sometimes
you're like oh man this situation isn't
working and Adams the CEO of Apple of it
yeah a CEO of Apple oven and you know
you have these situations where it's
like I got to go do the X or you really
feel like you got to go make this move
this deals bad maybe
I was bad or this I was good or
something like that I'll be what kind of
weight on it a little bit after deciding
and you could create some time what's a
good time to do it for n was like okay
we'll just go do this now
like what's stopping us and then you
know the other things like that were you
know I started there as kind of an
engineer and then very quickly he was
like oh you could run this team you
could manage the whole team I was a
great we talked and then that kind of
always been my experience that like that
never really gets communicated and then
it feels like cool I'm like the manager
but not like I think a lot of people end
up in that situation especially in
companies and then like the next morning
is like a meeting with the whole team he
puts the org chart up and then every
time we changed it the same situation
happened he was so clear and effective
with his communication and execution
that I was like like I really need to be
like that like that's what like I think
a plus execution looks and feels like
day in and day out and it's like it's
not emotional it's very logical it's
very quick and I think speed in these
situations helps create clarity because
when you arrive for the other way around
clarity help create speed yeah or both
right like you know and I think clarity
in the sense if you delay it your team
becomes unclear and then it gets a
little muddy and then you're like wait
what is what's going on here why is this
guy kind of acting like that and that
person not and I think just being very
fast and quick in that execute once you
decide you should go and execute it and
I think that that's that's the thing
that I learned is like how quickly can
you do that and how effectively can you
do that whether it's an email and I'm
really not good at this it's kind of one
of the reasons I pointed it because I
see myself kind of like oh wait on this
a little bit or send this email tomorrow
I don't know open up this can of worms
right now like and then it's actually
that's the exact opposite trades like
just go have a bias for action and and
kind of go do that and so from him I
learned just just an amazing amount in
like how do you operate at this level
and I mean since I've left they've grown
so much that it feels like I was only at
the 1% of it like I feel like I don't
know 90% 99% of the story anymore
because they've grown well beyond that
they've expanded into other areas
they're really big now from the revenue
side they're really big now from you
know what their marketplace is and
they're very well known and you know I
kind of get all the benefit from from
being there a long time ago which is
great for me but you know I'm sure there
were more learning
I missed along the way
[Music]